we do not miss the pandemic we had so
much time we finished tvs and still with
all the time we had left whenever that
one number we're called we look at the
phone like i ain't got time for this
[Applause]
hit the curb like it's running i can't
stand the double standard of dating
you're facing the following charges
being consistently picky and having
unreasonable standards my standards are
not unreasonable you know what to hold
you at night you rub shea butter on the
middle of your back my eggs are frozen
solid i got time time from where but i
will throw out your frozen eggs and i
will make a grand slam white people love
electricity that is y'all's ministry
let's just see
i'm a child of an immigrant i grew up
with you
and you better be back by fbn but then
the day starts at seven you bet that
fast
[Music]
mom dad i think it's time for me to
spread my weight are you moving up
because you're pregnant no prostitute no
dragon prostitutes
i have a brother who believes in his
heart that he grew up like tupac
you know daddy wasn't there he's right
there we have the same daddy
you